welcome to Python programming my name is
Richard Kirchner with the simply learned
team that's WW simply learn comm get
certified get ahead if you have any
questions on the video or have other
additional questions too what's covered
in here feel free to business at
wwlp.com or you can even post a note
down below the YouTube because we do
monitor those comments in this video
we're gonna cover the installation of
Python and PyCharm and we'll go over
variables will cover numbers strings and
then the input method we'll follow that
up with lists if-else and for loop once
we've covered those basics we'll get
into the wild loop nested loops
functions dictionary arrays and we'll
even set up a simple hangman game now
before we dive into writing script and
actually typing in some code we need a
package to type that in an IDE a user
interface so we're gonna use pycharm you
can see here welcome to pycharm as the
window that opens up for me and the
reason we use PyCharm there's a few
others out there pycharm and jupiter
notes are probably the most common ones
PyCharm creates virtual environments
that means whatever i'm doing in pycharm
is separate from the rest of my computer
and it's processes as it's going on that
way I'm not worried about corrupting
things or messing something up and it's
its own little world so whatever I'm
doing is in that world which makes it a
really powerful tool so you can install
Python on your computer direct or you
can install it in a protected box like
pycharm creates in the virtual
environment and usually I always bring
up the search engine I just to town load
Python you don't know how many searches
I do for these things because I never
remember what they're where they're at
then you go to the Python original site
now this will install it on the computer
so that any program can access it when
you do it this way and this is where
Python comes from welcome to Python org
you can go up here and there's all kinds
of documentation x' downloads if you go
to downloads i always suggest going to
the full list of downloads and going
back one version and the reason is is
whatever you're working on if you're
working with data science which python
is well known for and that's probably
this biggest growing field right now is
in the data science industry you really
want to be careful because there's a lot
of packages that won't run on Python 3 7
which just came out in this case maybe
it's three eight by the time you watch
this so I always go back and view the
full list of downloads and then you go
debt backed by Juan you look for three
six and so I'm running everything in
three six on this demo just for that
reason because that's what I have
installed I'll probably eventually
upgrade all my modules into Python three
seven once I know that they're solid now
you don't need to install Python
directly on your machine this is if
you're gonna run your code on your
computer and do something else with it
later on
so save this if you're just getting
started in Python don't worry about this
part this is for later on but you need
to know that python is its own code and
script so I do the same thing I go
download PyCharm
again I like my search engines I never
remember what I put where this will open
up your features pipe charm psyched and
once you're under here you can go up to
the download page and this will open up
your downloads and you have download
PyCharm you know the professional
version if you want to pay money this
actually in the long run if you're
running a business or corporation allows
you to integrate your different
programmers together so it's a really
powerful tool as a company but as an
individual the community version the
lightweight IDE is perfect one it's open
source so it's free which is really nice
so jetbrains makes their money off of
the pycharm they make it by selling a
commercial version a professional
version but the community version works
just fine and then once you've run the
install you'll see here will you have
this icon with the PC with the green and
yellow background pycharm setup and then
we open it that's where we started off
at and we'll go ahead and just create a
new project
I'll look hot pycharm python basics
that's that's what we're covering today
and I've already set PyCharm I've
already set my default path to where I
put my different programming stuff in
and since this is for simply learning
that's my path I put in their default
creates a PyCharm folder and you can
change this path to wherever you want it
and whatever you're working on go ahead
and create this project here and this is
setting up literally a virtual
environment again it's a box that
separates
the rest of my computer so I don't have
to worry whatever I do in here if I even
working in Python three six I can create
another box that has Python three seven
I can then take that code open it up and
see if it runs in three seven see if
there's a problem with the modules and
the version numbers so very important
thing to know we don't need to worry
about that with this because this is
already set to three six and everything
we're doing in here is basic Python so
we'll work in any of the Python versions
you download and then once we're in here
we're gonna create a new scratch file
and you just go straight to new scratch
file or you can click on new and you'll
see you have some different setups
depending on what's going on and this
one I don't have anything special setup
on it so it only allows me to add a
scratch file to the project and then you
have all your choices of what kind of
scratch files you can do a lot of
different stuff in pycharm it's not
limited to just python even though
that's what it's made for but python can
be used as a back-end for your server
setup so you can actually do a call a
Python file on the server just like you
can call number of other files and no
one ever sees it and then it comes back
as an HTML code there's all kinds of
cool things you can do it's a full
programming language that's why there's
such a shift to Python with the data
science used to be primarily an R and
once you've set it up here you'll see
and I actually have a bunch of different
scratches have gone on over over time
where's just scratch one two three you
can always rename these if you
right-click on it you'll see refactor
rename so let's say I don't want to call
it scratch three we won't actually call
it pycharm well this is called Python
basic Python goes to Python pycharm
basics and refractor and refractor means
it's going through and if you have a
number of files that are referencing
this one it'll refract or all of them so
they point in the right direction that's
one of the nice things about using these
IDE s they do a lot of the work for you
and then we have our code we can just
start typing our code in here on the
right and we always start this is like
the number one programmers code hello
world so we'll just type in print hello
world you'll see that hello world is in
brackets and then if we go under run you
can run it this way you could also do
alt shift f10 that's the same thing as
running and this is going to run this
code it's gonna ask you which code are
you gonna run you can add a
configuration but it'll automatically
default to what you're working
and it rinses code and then you see a
box appear down below and what we have
down below is a console setup and so
it's run the program here's our hello
world it printed it out and you can see
I've got the font sized up a little bit
so hopefully you can see it well and
then process finish it and exit code and
if you've gotten this far
congratulations you just ran your first
coat your first coat and pie chart print
HelloWorld let's go ahead and show you
something down here you can see the
window opened up down on the bottom and
there's tabs on the very bottom you'll
see python console terminal run and to
do and so this is a run window the
terminal window literally opens a
terminal environment where I can type in
whatever I want on here this is for
doing installing and things like that
we're not going to cover that today but
I do want to cover Python console and
oops oh yeah a little pop-up because my
windows firewall so just allow access to
it it's a console basically you can run
straight off a console so I can print
hello world and if I go to the end of my
console I hit enter you'll see it does
the same thing it prints hello world and
so I could run it line by line down here
or I can type in all my code and run all
the lines at once
that's what the difference is between
doing it as a and they call it a scratch
we're doing it as a Python file versus
doing it in the console now I'll do some
stuff in the console if I forget what my
code is or what I'm doing so I might
forget how the heck do I do print was it
print brackets hello world and you'll
see that I left out the quotation marks
and it comes up as says Oh syntax error
I know oh that wasn't right so we
definitely have a little options here
some few options just to check out your
code as you're going and you can see you
can quickly make sure it's doing what
you want to do in the console and some
people do like all their coding in the
console and amazes me I can't do that I
have to see my code as it's going up
here and rerun it over and over again
and it brings us back to our run code
down below in PyCharm there are a lot of
different settings and things you can do
in here real quick let's go under file
and under settings and this has your
appearance your menus your system
settings and go down here your editor
project version version controls very
important cuz then come down here and
see what's in
background what's going on it has all
kinds of interfaces but even more
important for the most basic set up is
you want to look at the project folder
you'll see project PyCharm Python basics
I remember I was talking about version 3
7 versus 3 6 when you click on the pull
down arrow you'll see the project
version here and you can see up here I'm
in Python 3 6 and let's say I wanted to
test my code in something else I only
have 3 6 installed on this particular
PyCharm version but I can add other
different Python versions in here so I
can do a plus on here and just add in
another setup I can add in different
tools and setups underneath here also
for this project and only this project
will use it so if I'm using Python 3 7
in my main environment and running stuff
I can now have a box and I can test it
on 3 6 or 3 8 when it comes out that way
I'm always up on the different Python
versions and economical check my code
and make sure it's gonna work in them
and we're gonna do a quick change in the
appearance I have it as font size 12
let's go in here and change all kinds of
stuff on here I'm just gonna bump this
way up by that okay just so you can see
what's going on better there we go nice
big bold font should done at the very
beginning so we have our print hello
let's start diving into the code this is
some exciting I don't know about you I
love to code and I love to try to figure
these things out how they fit together
well we did our first program we did
print hello world but now we want to do
a little bit more and we want to go
ahead and print but we wanted to
actually do something not just display
it so we're gonna go ahead and put the
sum is and you'll see here we have it's
gonna print just like we did print hello
world we're gonna add a comma in so I
can print different objects and separate
them with a comma and I can actually do
the code right in here and this is part
of the Python way is you do the code
wherever you can they call it the python
wakes it looks very simple and we'll
show you some other variations of this
in just a minute but we can do this sub
miss and we have 5 plus 10 and if you
remember we can go under run and that's
also an alt shift FS 10 I'm gonna do
that one alt shift f10 and then just hit
enter it's already on the python pycharm
basics and you can see here we have our
original one that says hello world and
then it says the sum is and this is nice
because already did the calculation for
us we did 5 plus 10 now if we wanted to
print 5 plus
and we would do five comma plus in
brackets tenth and so if I run this one
you will see that this prints very
differently this one comes in and says
the sum is five plus ten doesn't give me
the answer well if we go back you just
do a control Z you'll get 5 plus 10 and
we get our answer on there and there's
our alt shift f10 and run the basics and
the sum is 15 and then we'll go ahead
just copy this line it'll put it down
here we can do the same thing but set a
plus we'll do - my insert has to be on I
will set this to 5 - 10 and if we run
that let's switch it around I like to
stay positive
this will create a negative 10 minus 5
doesn't matter really which direction
you go in and if we do the run you'll
see that I go back and forth how I run
it we get 5 10 minus 5 and you could
just as easily change this at 2 let's do
5 times 10 and then we'll also do 10
divided by 5 and this is not the sum but
the difference and this is the product
and instead of the sum we'll have the
quotient and so if I run these and by
the ways there's like so many different
ways to run this I've been doing ctrl
shift alt f10 I've gone to the top it
also has the bar up here you can turn
off the toolbar and you can run the run
off of here and it does the same thing
and you can see here we have the sum is
15 the difference is 5 10 minus 5 the
product is 50 and the quotient is 2.0 so
it's actually converted this to float
value or decimal value and number for us
now this is great if all you wanted to
know was the sum of fit 1 5 and 10 and
the difference of 10 + 5 + 5 + 10 + 10 +
5 let's just go ahead and remove all
this stuff take that all out delete
there we go before I do this let me just
introduce the pound or hash tag if you
see that in Python that means this is a
comment ignore this line so if I want to
put notes in here like what if we wanted
to change 5 and 10 to 10 and 15 what if
it happens if we if our code is coming
in and we don't know what 5 and 10 or
it's gonna be 10 and 15 or we don't even
know what it is we're gonna be doing I
really don't want to have to read
type that code all the time and when
you're programming that should always be
on your mind if you're doing a lot I
think you saw how I did that copy and
paste remember I was pasting it in and
then changing it if you're doing a lot
of that chances are you need to fix your
code a little bit when you first start
though that's okay and certainly while
you're writing your code you're gonna be
doing that a lot and then you simplify
it down we're gonna create a variable
and we'll call it a in this case I'm
using capital a you can use lowercase a
general terms if I'm using a single
letter for some things I'll use a
capitalized depending on what I'm doing
on other things will be lowercase like a
and lowercase there we go and nor the
pop ups that's different things to begin
with a that's part of pycharm gives you
a list of all kinds of things code you
can put in there so but we'll go capital
a and we're going to assign to a five
and so this is just like if you were
taking your class in basic algebra where
you have x equals 5 y plus c XY and c
are variables so a equals 5 and we'll
enter on that we'll do B equals 10 and
then we can go ahead and do some let's
do capital S we'll stick with the same
setup on here you gotta be a little
careful with some because there are
certain modules that use it as a regular
we'll use some you know what I'm gonna
go ahead and do lowercase because that
is more standard to do some except that
it will create an actual module so we
don't want to do that we'll use capital
S there we go that's where they did
capital S some equals a plus B and then
we'll do difference equals a and we'll
do product equals a times B and we'll do
call it instead of quotient well do div
equals over a so the same thing we did
before but we're now assigning them to
variables so now we have all these
variables and here's our print statement
the sum is and instead of putting 5 and
10 here we'll just put down some and we
had the other ones I'll do this can
there's a copy and paste so at some
point I'd probably want to ask is there
a way I can simplify that but we'll do
difference so the difference is diff it
will do product so there's our variable
PR OD for product
and the product is and then finally our
quotient quotient is so we look at this
code here we can see we have a equals
five B equals ten sum of a plus B
difference of B minus a product of a
times B and div of B over a and then we
go ahead and display the different
mathematic answers there let's go ahead
and run that I'll just click on the Run
button up here cuz I like that it's
actually quick and easy we'll bring this
up so you can see the bottom here and
sure enough the sum is 15 the difference
is 5 the product is 50 the quotient is
20 so we just ran a code that actually
does some mathematics behind it a very
basic code and you can see how as we
continue to add our different tools in
we can manipulate numbers and do all
kinds of fun things with our Python
script now these very basic math
functions are so common that they're
built into the basic Python setup but
there's more so we're going to go ahead
and explore numbers more and you can see
this is just a title I've added that
little hash tag at the beginning so the
code will be ignored so it's just for a
comment and we'll go ahead and stick
with our a be a equals 5 B equals minus
10 I've got a print so in addition to
before we did all the plus minus times
divide you can also do power so if we
wanted to do say a P tilde thing squared
the command for that is P Oh W a comma 2
and the stands for power so a to the
second power you can do a cube a to the
fourth power and so on and we'll go
ahead and run this and let's bring this
back up so you can see what's going on
underneath and we get 5 squared is 25
and that's what we expect on there it's
pretty straightforward at this point we
want to go ahead and import math and
math is a module outside of the basic
Python but it's included in all the
Python installs it's so commonly used
but you still have to import it for a
lot of things and one of those is doing
the square root if we want to print
let's give her a little print a title
we're doing square root comma first we
mention the module e import it
and this is math and then period and sq
RT of a and if we run this you'll see
down here that the square root is two
point two three six and so on and so on
and I can read the whole number and
there's a lot of different commands in
here you can also print let's do the
absolute value and I'll show you in just
a second where to look this up and
there's our comma I'm two different we
have our string absolute and then we can
do absolute value of B remember B is
minus ten so when I run this the
absolute value should be ten we can also
do complex numbers let me show you that
on here print and always give it a nice
label so we know we're talking about
complex number comma and they can do
complex I will do a comma B for complex
and let's run that and see what that and
we get 5 minus 10 J is how the output
shows on that as a complex number on
there so I do a search for Python math
and the stay in the 3 version let me
just open that window up and mathematic
function is 3/7 documentation this is
the official Python website with the
documentation that shows all the
different things when you use the math
module math ceiling math copy sign fabs
factorial scroll down here little bit it
could be a little hard to read because
it lists them what they do and how they
return them it's important though to get
used to reading these because sometimes
you go down here and you need to double
check exactly what you're doing here's
our math dot P o W for power remember we
did that
there's our square root we did log
functions there's tangent cosine or a
cosine a tangent to trigonometry
functions tangent degrees hyperbolic
function even have PI in here if you
need to add PI in their math PI there's
a lot of different things in here and
meet the math module and then of course
we'll just go down to wikibooks is
probably okay they're very simplistic
but you can see right here
our basic functions in math and what we
covered a plus B a minus B a times B a
divided by b floor division available
and python 2 2 and later python 3 so
that's not a problem
amber sign is important because that's
your remainder i surprised how often i
use it i think i never use it but i
actually end up using that
of course your mind again you can sit
absolute value and then we did the
exponent aid ^ B this is similar to the
same thing as doing the math power so
you can also do a double x on here and
then the math square root of a so you
can come in here and see that just about
anything you're looking for in algebra
you're gonna find it in these functions
and then you need to explore just a
little bit so we've been talking about a
lot of functions on here in numbers let
me just clear that out of there what
happens if I do print let's do the
letter A plus five what do you think is
gonna happen there we have the letter A
plus the number five it's gonna give us
an error must be a string not an integer
so tells you what's wrong with it it
says hey you can't add the letter A to
five I don't know what to do with that
and you'll get an error on there let's
do something a little fun with this
let's write a little piece of code
finding if a number is our strong number
and I have to Google this I didn't know
what an Armstrong number was when they
sent me the code so what is an Armstrong
number where's an Armstrong number is an
N digit number that is equal to the sum
of the empowers of its digits so it's
kind of fun is this what an Armstrong
number is I guess it's a common thing
you can try out to find just go ahead
and do ours and see if we can figure
that out
how do we write a code to compute if
something is an arm strong number so
we're gonna go do an import math because
we're gonna be using the power and I
don't really have to import the math I
could actually use the time remember
that math dot POW or you can do the x
times to also get the power but we'll go
ahead and do it under the math so we'll
import our math importing another module
and then we'll have in equals integer
and we need an input enter a number so
there's a lot of stuff going on in here
this here is true pieces of code put
together input says hey I need to prompt
you for something on the command line
let's go ahead and run it just this
piece of code and see what comes up this
is enter a number and then I can enter
down below you'll see where it comes up
in my run should prompt me into a number
and then this number 20 and then it
continues on so when I enter the number
is now assigning it to in let me add a
space in there except just looks better
I will just print and let's just do just
this piece of codes you can see what's
going on here so run down below is
in our number I type in 20 I hit enter
and it prints 20 so now in is our
variable int means this is going to be
of a data type integer so if I run this
and I type in 20 point to enter it's
gonna give me an error cuz 20.2 is not
an integer it's a number but it's got
decimals quick note that this isn't
forcing it to be an integer and I flip
over and say what are the different
number types in Python you should be
asking that question and you'll see here
I always try to go to the main Python
documentation whenever I can
now you can reference other reference
material but you always want to go to
the main reference and the reason is is
that it will give you what's actually in
the Python and check your version and
see what version you have on there and
so you have numerical types integer
float long and complex are the common
ones that we're gonna be looking at
we're not going to cover all of these
most of are pretty straightforward you
know what an integer is versus just a
regular number a float value long these
is just carries more digits and then we
can get into complex numbers which we
looked at briefly earlier so we've
learned how to input set up in here and
let's go ahead and the next step is to
figure out what the length is so how
many digits are in this number well
let's do L equals we wonder the links
Lynn stands for links and this has to be
a string so we haven't really talked
much about strings but a string is like
the letter A was a string it was a
string of one letter so we want to turn
this into a string you can just do STR
to tell it's going to be a string of n
so I've now computed the length of the
string of N and if we come up here if
you remember correctly we did print in
on this print string of n on here you
know what let's take this exit out of
there bring it down a notch and let's
just also do a comma L so we're gonna
print it as a number as a string and as
a links and we'll do 20 you'll see that
20 is a number 20 is a strain they look
identical and it's linked to it's got
two digits in it pretty straightforward
so far we're pretty good we're gonna be
adding up the powers of those so it's
important to get the length of the
string of each one and let's do number
equals in sum equals zero and wild
number who a while loop it's exciting
remainder equals number then there's
amber sign I think I mentioned that very
briefly by 10 a sum equals sum I don't
kind of flashing through this so we're
gonna walk through this just a second if
you're getting lost and see what's going
on there we go and number equals number
10 so this is the computation just going
to figure out because we have in our
original value and we've set number
equal to N and we have some equals zero
so what's going on here is that we want
to find out if the number we've picked
in this case 20 is an Armstrong number
so we're gonna continually add the sum
up of the power of the remainder and
when you're looking at this you say
remainder where does remainder come into
this set up well the remainder comes in
here because when we divide by 10 so if
I do let's do 22 divided by 10 you have
a remainder of two we basically just
pulled that last digit off so it's just
kind of a trick to pull the last digit
off and we're gonna take that 2 and
we're gonna do 2 ^ in this case the
length of L so 2 in this case there's
only power of 2 so L to the power of 2
then we need to reset our number and so
this gives us the value of the number
without the remainder so we basically
this comment here
rym gives us the remainder so we're
gonna pop that off and use that to
compute and to our sum and then we're
gonna take the number we're gonna set it
back 1 so while we have a number we're
gonna keep doing this so if we did 20
you'll pop the zero off and then I'll
pop the two off and then I'll say hey
there's nothing left in number it's
empty that's what this is doing and then
we have the sum sum equals sum plus math
power so we're adding it to itself and
you can actually do this the shorthand
for this instead of doing some plus the
shorthand for this in Python is plus
equals math dot power so we're doing the
REM to the power of the links so this is
a shorthand you can do and by putting
the plus sign before the equals sign it
just means we're adding it to the sum
now there are times when I do that and
there are times when my computations are
so complex that I just get lost if I do
that it's okay to put it out here and
just do some equals sum plus math power
so now we've summed up all these values
and how do we know if it's an Armstrong
well we need if if
equals in so if they are equal we can
print
let's do yay Armstrong Armstrong number
when I write here Armstrong I always
think of Neil Armstrong the first man on
the moon but yea Armstrong number okay
so we got an Armstrong number and this
is an if statement in here and else you
can do an if and an else and else print
if we did yeah this dubu just be fun
this is not an Armstrong number Ballu
oops
there we go boo a couple things to know
here with the if you'll see that instead
of doing equals sum has to have a double
equals now you can also do less than
greater than we can do the exclamation
point for not equals but whenever you do
equals remember to put in two equal
signs this generates a yes or no true
false and if it's true it will execute
this next piece of code which is
indented Python indentation is very
important but I got to mention that with
the while you'll see the while
automatically indented here same with
the elf if and the same with the else so
run the if the sum equals and he'll
print yeah Armstrong number else I'll
print boo this is not an Armstrong
number so we read a nice little piece of
code e we've actually written the whole
code let's go ahead and run this and
you'll see here's our number down here
well put in 20 I don't think 20 is an
Armstrong number just because two to the
power of two is four and it says boo
this is not an Armstrong number and then
we could also do I don't even sure how
to get an Armstrong number maybe 200 no
that wouldn't be an Armstrong number
because I like to succeed I went ahead
and typed in Armstrong numbers and I
came up with looks like someone found
one for 371 so let's go ahead and run
this with 371 since we know that's an
existing Armstrong number 371 and
Armstrong number 371 you could also type
in I found out when I was playing with
this the first time i typed in one was
the only one I could come up with on my
own
I'm sure there's a lot of them so yeah
we just read a simple code to predict if
a number is an arm strong number here
it's a few lines of code we have our
input so we learned about the input we
learned about lengths kind of our second
short view of strings which we're going
to get more into and then we did a while
to loop through the number to find out
to add
and summit and didn't figure out if it's
Armstrong number so we've covered a lot
of things on numbers let's move on and
take a look at strings we've looked just
a little bit of strings in here so we're
gonna come back and take a look at
strings there we go and let's go and put
our comment in there that we're gonna be
working with strings and let's create a
couple of variables we'll start with
variable 1 equals let's do welcome and
I'm gonna add a space in there and then
we'll do variable two and we'll set that
equal to simply learn so when you're
working with variables if you notice
earlier we did a plus five and we ran
that and it gave us an error because you
can't add a string to a number it
doesn't know what to do with it so
there's two things I want you to notice
here one we've assigned variable strings
and then we're going to take the
variables we're gonna do variable one
plus variable two so I was assigned
variable one welcome and variable to
assign to simply learn and when we do
variable one plus variable two and we
run it we get welcome to simply learn
and I had to add the space in there
because it takes two strings
it doesn't really there are ways to
track spaces in the string and do things
with that but the basic variable doesn't
know to add a space in there so if I do
this it'll be welcome to and you'll see
there's no space between the two and the
welcome so we got to make sure we add
that space in there when working with
variables this is simple we just printed
variable one and variable to this
concatenates the two variables together
just like you think it would it's
important the term concatenation is very
common means that we're adding a second
one in line to the first one so you're
not gonna get to simply learn welcome
unless you switch the two around of
course and we can do other things we can
do print variable then we're gonna do is
see what's do variable to and we're
gonna do brackets and we haven't talked
about brackets because the string is an
array we're actually gonna get into
arrays later on so it's important to
note this is an array of letters and we
do 0 2 3 and so we have our indexes our
index is 0 and our index of 3 and let me
go ahead and print this so you can see
what's going on and it prints just to2
and if we did variable 1 that's kind of
fun and we run that and it prints well
wel
so the indices have zero zero refers to
the first position and that's true of
all your scripting languages and so we
have 0 1 2 and you would think well why
doesn't it print 3 in there let me just
do this because it's kind of fun to say
we so if I do a variable 0 to 2 that
should be 0 1 2 it doesn't include the
last position in the array that's very
important to note and there's a lot of
reasons for that programmatically but we
are creating a slice so this is a slice
from 0 to less than 2 which in this case
is 0 1 which is we and then we can also
print
let's do variable let's do 2 and we'll
do it this way 3 on let's run that and
you'll see that this prints simply learn
well how did I get simply learned from
there well we have 0 1 2 and then I
start at 3 that's the S and by leaving
this one blank it goes all the way to
the end that's all this says it's 3 to
the end and I can do that also with the
first one instead of putting 0 to 2 I
could do just everything up to 2 and I
still get the wheat w/e down here and if
I do 3 on I get 3 on which is simply
learn and of course if we did no numbers
on here let's just do that separately
does occur believe it or not but it's
usually not something you use very often
you would show everything that's all it
does is here's our variable 2 to simply
learn so prints all of it on there and
then earlier we already did this but
we'll do it again print link le in for
links and we'll do a variable
let's do variable 1 and so when we run
that it comes down here and says it's 8
long so we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
don't forget that blank space has to be
counted in variable 1 we have 8 letters
in there and again we did that earlier
when we did our Armstrong number so I
should look familiar and then you can
also look up an index so we're gonna
print variable dot index and we'll look
up see om and these are very common
things we do we search through the words
to find things so this is a built-in
method of strings and we'll run this and
it's going to print the index of coem
except they forgot to put variable 1 so
it's giving me a little bit of error
there so let's run it we'll see 3 is the
end
so the seaso 0 1 2 3 4 C CEO M and I
could easily do Mei could do just the
letter C and I'll go through and find
the first index of C with strings this
is a little bit weird because you almost
have to be really specific with whatever
you're trying to do but we'll go Python
string functions which will take us to
let's go to the official site I always
try to go to the official site in this
case three point six this is what we're
in or two point seven isn't gonna matter
too much because it's been around so
long and you can see here's all of our
string in common string operations
converting it to digits letters
lowercase there's so many things in here
you can do uppercase whitespace
formatting which we're gonna look at in
just a minute there's a lot of things
you can do with strings so you have to
be a little bit more specific with
whatever it is you're trying to do and
chances are there's a quick way to do it
that you can look up so what we're gonna
do though is we're gonna take a look at
some of these just a few of these just
to give you an idea of some of the
things you can do but one of the things
for readability that's so important and
actually you know what let me go ahead
and start this over a little bit here so
clean my palate a little bit we're gonna
create a variable equal to and I'm gonna
do the single asterisks but I'm gonna do
three of them and you'll see in the
pycharm format it automatically creates
two sets of three and this is a very
useful when you're writing code because
what it does it says hey anything
between these two sets of three single
asterisks is going to be a string
variable so I can do welcome and I can
do two and I can do Python and then I
can print variable and let's go ahead
and run that and see what that looks
like
scrolled up just a little bit here a
couple things to know first off we split
our string on three different lines so
it's much more readable if you're doing
a lot of programming you might have a
very lengthy thing going on where you're
doing the path or something like that
where you really want to spread out so
you can see what's going on and it's
also important to note that it added a
carriage return it registers that
carriers return as part of the string so
when it prints it out you'll see welcome
to Python as three separate lines and
that's why you can't see the carriage
return here or the line break but it's
in there and that's when we print this
variable that's what you're gonna get
but you can split it in multiple lines
it makes a little bit more readable
so let me clear this out again
we would keep a nice big screen going so
it's a hopefully easier to read let's
talk just a little bit about formatting
there's a lot of different things you
can do with formatting let's go ahead
and create name equals Sam place equals
Florida variable equals so we're gonna
create a variable and this one's going
to be hi create brackets followed by an
exclamation point that's a place so the
brackets are important they actually
register in the variable as being
something other than brackets and then
we can do
welcome to let another set of brackets
and a period at the end so we have
proper punctuation and I'm gonna format
this and we're gonna format this with
name and place and what this is doing is
maybe you're printing out labels so
maybe this is a full address or
something like that so it's fun about
this as I can do print I print out my
variable and we run this and you can see
that it's replaced the first set and the
second set of brackets with Sam in
Florida so we have a nice hi Sam
welcome to Florida this is kind of fun
because we can actually take these
brackets and let's say the order is
different let's do 1 and 0 and remember
when we're talking about counting we
always start with 0 so name is in the
zero place places in the one place and
if you can guess what we just did we
said hi Florida welcome to Sam another
way to do placeholders is with the amber
sign and let's also mix in an input I
know we already did inputs before but
we'll do it again
so we're inputting a from the user so
we'll do name equals input enter your
name and then I can do a scoop in or
backward slash in I always called scoop
in because that's I wish remember I've
never remembered backward slash I
remember scoop in for some reason this
is your carriage return if you wanted to
print an actual backward slash it be
backslash backslash so this is how you
print a backslash or inner backslash as
a variables with double backslash
because the backslash is an escape
character so whatever comes after it
gives it special meaning and in this
case a backward slash followed by the N
is the same as a carriage return so it
puts in a newline and we're sending name
equal to input into your name if you
remember we did a number earlier just
like that we said enter a number and we
set it equal to an integer
and we said to a variable so it's the
same thing we're just entering a string
this time having any print hi space
remember doesn't register space name and
if I run this I'll say enter your name
and my name happens to be Richard Salini
Richard says hi Richard exciting there
and notice the spacing on here why does
it have the extra spacing well we put a
comma in so a comma separates everything
I could have just as easily added my two
strings together and run it this way
make sure I have my space after the hi
and I run it this way and now I'll just
have put my name in there again enter hi
Richard just a single space on here so
it changes the spacing sometimes it gets
confusing because the common like I said
is just a basic tab in between I believe
is what it does so we have print hi
Richard in this case we could also do
with formatting print so we're gonna do
print again and here's our hi and then
I'm gonna put the amber sign s period is
punctuation but the amber sign s is
what's important how are you question
mark and then because it's a marker we
can then add it afterwards as an Amber
sign this used to be so common I saw
this all the time
so part you're gonna say how come we
don't just use the brackets and use this
instead this used to be the standard
they introduced that is also another
standard and so both of them worked
quite well and you can see we do name so
that's our placeholder in there for the
name and if we run this it's gonna ask
me to enter name Richard enter hi
Richard how are you and then from before
if you remember we entered a number so
we're gonna do age equals and one thing
could be an integer how old are you
let's do input and then we need the
prompt for the input enter your age and
I guess we're doing to make the enter it
on the next line down and then we'll
print you are here's our placeholder
with the Amber sign
I'll call amber sign D your old bracket
and then we'll do Amber sign age to put
that in there so here we have you are
and then here's our placeholder year-old
and then the age and we'll go ahead and
run this so you can see that it says
enter your name so go down here we enter
my name Richard hi Richard hi Richard
how are you and then
I'm gonna enter my age and they say
you're only as young as you feel
and today I'm filling 30 which is well
below my actual age but we'll do 30
today I'm actually in my 30 so you are
30 years old so you can see how we
reformatted the setup on here and we've
now printed out using two different
forms of place markers and this brings
us to lists are we gonna do we can do
lists dictionaries lists dick welcome to
'pls first two polls will explore while
loops and we'll get into dictionaries
and other fun stuff so we'll start with
lists list is the most basic collection
of items in the Python language
none of the languages you might hear
references to an array there's a lot of
different names but list is the proper
terminology and we'll go ahead just call
it LST for our variable so we're gonna
set a variable LST equal to our list and
a list is setup with square brackets and
then you can put your objects in here
separated by commas and you'll see here
we have one two three four five and we
can even mix and match our data types so
in Python you have a lot of leeway so
you can see here we have one two three
four
commas simply learn so we have an item
with has five items in it and a list we
looked at this just a little bit when we
looked at strings because remember a
string is also a list so this is a list
of numbers and a sub list of a string
which is also a list of characters well
look at that is a little bit more closer
here in a second from here we can do a
print and there's our variable LST and
then we can reference it just like we
did above we use the square brackets and
I can say reference to that's going to
be the second position and if you guess
that that is equal to three you're
correct
because we always start with 0 0 1 2
puts us in the 3 mark right there so
this is our basic list and you can see
we have our basic index referencing the
list and just like we did before we can
also do negative so this could be a list
minus 4 and if we're doing - 4 let's go
ahead and run that you'll see 3 for end
exit 2 and then 2 is their index of
minus 4 so counting this one from this
and that's minus 1 minus 2 minus 3 minus
and this is interesting there's a reason
they do this when you start writing
programs to reference different aspects
of this list you'll find that it makes a
lot more sense minus 0 is nothing so it
always starts going backwards at minus 1
because minus 0 equals 0 so it still go
is going to equal once you can't really
make it a minus 0 so we start with minus
1 minus 2 3 & 4 puts us at the 2 point
and there are a number of properties to
the list that gives us all kinds of
control of it list dot append will
append a 3 to it lists are dynamic
meaning we can change the contents and
we can add to it and subtract from it so
if we list a pen 3 and then we go ahead
and print our list let's just take will
reset this so we've got not collecting a
lot of things on here so if we print our
list we now have 1 2 3 4 simply learn
and 3 so there's our list and it
continues to grow also know we've
repeated we have two 3s in here so
there's no there's nothing in here that
says that they have to be unique there's
ways to do that but in a basic list they
don't have to be unique and they're just
indexed by their location and we can do
list dot remove so you can remove we'll
put in simply learn and if we do this
and then we print our list again and we
run that you can see that we have 1 2 3
4 simply learn 3 we've removed the value
out of there simply learn and we end up
with 1 2 3 4 3 and we can also do a
reverse we could just skip the setting
list changes we can do print list dot
vers let's run that and you'll see oops
it came out 1 I messed up on their list
reverse we can do a list reverse and if
we print list and we run that we end up
with 3 4 3 2 1 going in Reverse and when
there's also a sort on here so we can do
list dot sort and if we print list let's
run that you can see we've sorted it out
1 2 3 3 4 just put it in order and this
would also work alphabetically so if you
had apple banana and whatever else it
would organize it by apple banana or one
two-three-four kind of a fun thing is to
see what happens where but simply learn
in here we'll take lists and go back to
our original one and sort that and run
it and it gives us an error so what
happens is it doesn't know how to
compare strings and integers so this is
important to note that even though you
can do all kinds of things with your
list and you can put multiple different
objects in the list you have to remember
that whatever logic is going on still
has to be able to work on both letters
and numbers on there and if I pop in
list operations in Python and do a quick
search you actually have to scroll down
a little bit to get to the official site
python.org data structures and list
overflow and we go underneath this
actually I found that two point seven
went into but I'm sure there's a three
point six and three point seven version
in here we look at data structures and
you can see that list really is one of
the basic objects in Python so you can
append we just looked at that you can
extend it you can insert it you can
remove we did that one there's a pop and
a push there's an index account sort
reverse there's all kinds of things you
can do and you can scroll down you'll
see there's different categories and
ways that they function and I would
suggest for this going to the Python
main site because this is the actual API
on here this is actually what you're
accessing and let's go ahead and
introduce the basic iteration through a
list or loop and the basic loop is
always a for loop and in Python you can
do for I in list and then what we can do
there's an indent my editor
automatically puts the intern in there
as we go and just print list and so
whoops not list I'll just put a bunch of
the list over and over again we want to
print I and so when we do this and we go
ahead and run this and let's go ahead
and pull up our output down here so you
can see it we end up with one two three
four five it just goes through the list
and takes an action on each one now if
you came from another programming
language or if you some of the older
languages way back in the 90s you would
have to do something more like this
range 0 length of list so you have a
starting point member it always starts
in zero and the range command only goes
up to but does not include the last
value which
is gonna be the links so length of this
is five but the last value is gonna be
four it's gonna be zero to four and
instead of print I we're gonna print
list and I'll put square brackets around
the eye just like we did before for
indexing and you'll see it gives us the
same answer one two three four five so
there's reason to do it with a range and
there's reason to not do it generally
when you're doing a for loop or
iterating through your data for I in
list is the most basic format and the
most pythonic formats it's very easy to
read and you know that you're just gonna
print I because I now represents each of
those values and knowing how to iterate
through things is so important in Python
along with the tuples and lists and and
this works by the ways if this was a
tuple or a list I could just as easy
you've created a tuple let's just do
that real quick so you can see control
copy TPL equals so here's our tuple in
circular brackets and i can do i and
tuple and we should get the same output
and you can see we do one two three four
so it works just the same as it doesn't
a list the difference is is i can't go
back and change a tuple I couldn't say
tuple a position three change that to
nine they'll throw an error but we could
certainly print and go through our tuple
just like we do through the list on here
just put that back list let's go run
there we go there's a lot of other
things we can do with the list you can
make a list of lists so we could have in
our list let's do it this way one two
three comma I'll do four five so not
even the same linked list doesn't care
about that unless you add some extra
things in there to make it force it into
the right size it'll go a B so we have a
totally different data type in this list
C as you can see here we have some very
different aspects and we'll just print
the list and run that and you'll see we
get the same list down here the one two
three four five ABC and just like we did
this before if we take this list you can
do for I enlist so there's our I let me
just do tab and we could print the I
like we did before so I'll print each of
the sub lists in here and you can see we
get one two three four five ABC we could
even do something go down a level we
could do for J and I because I as now
also
this or sublist and we have to end in
our print we'll do print J if we do that
you'll see it comes one two three four
five ABC just flattens it out and prints
each digit one at a time on there Dan
let's go ahead and reset our list to a
single list so we got one two three four
five rid of all this here's our four I
will keep our four I change this just a
very basic logic the if-else statement
so we can do if I and we look at the
remainder what it looks like let's / -
so if it's seven / - you're gonna have a
remainder of one
if it's 6 / - you have a remainder of
zero so if I remainder two or the
remainder of I divided by two equals
zero put our colon here make sure you
have your indent and if there's a no
remainder on here let's print let's see
we can do here we have oh let's do our
placeholder so we have formatted text is
even and then we'll do placeholder so we
know that this is gonna go there I so
print if this is even placeholder I
double check okay and they'll do an else
so if it's not even then it's gonna be
what odd and we'll do the whole thing
again I'll just copy this there we go
print is hot and then we have a
placeholder I let's see what this looks
like when we run it just a quick way to
iterate through the data so we're
iterating through the data if it has no
remainder divided by two that it's got
to be even and if it does have a
remainder else it's odd even or odd and
hopefully you caught it I was so busy
typing it in I didn't catch the dollar
sign I accidentally hit fix that and now
we go ahead and run it and we have one
as odd two was even three is odd for is
even five is odd just like we expect it
five is an odd number now earlier I
hinted at tuple a little bit kind of
jump the gun there
you create a tuple by putting brackets
around instead of square brackets you
use the curved brackets that denotes
it's a tuple now a tuple and a lot of
respects it's a sub object of list so it
has a lot of the same things you have a
list to print the tuple down here you'll
see one two three four five and it has
curb brackets around it I can go in here
and if you remember from before I can
print me do this let's go print tuple
and we'll use an index index of three I
guess I didn't need to retype all that I
could just on the index of three in the
index of 3 is 4 because we go 0 1 2 3
and this puts us at the 4 value so it's
the same index we can't sort it we can't
reverse it we can't change it I can't
come in here if you remember if we had a
list with a list I could come in here
and say a list of 2 equals lucky 7 there
we go
and if I print the list you'll see down
here that it has 1 2 7 4 but if I do
this with the tuple let's take the tuple
here you take off my index it doesn't
print just the index and we'll do list
instead of the list let's do the triple
of 2 equals 7 and if I run that it's
gonna give me an error why because we
can't change a tuple I can change the
overall value I can come down here and
say okay the tuples worth this now my
variable tuple is worth a or want us to
a b c so i can change the tuple variable
but i can't change anything in the tuple
and let me run that and see i still get
an error because I have my tuple 2
equals 7 let's run that without that and
you'll see it's now worth ABC or 1 2 3 4
5 but if I try to change a digit in
there
and when you do a reverse or a sort or
anything like that on the list it
actually changes the individual
variables and this is also true if I
have a list of lists let me do my list
equals oh let's do 1 2 3 , it'll make
this a tuple 4 5 6 I can change these
aspects of the list the 1 2 3 and I can
change out the position number 1 index 1
which is a 4 5 6 but I can't change
anything in the 4 5 6 so if I print list
it'll come out down here as 1 2 3 4 5 6
and if you said let me run it it's gonna
give me an error you're correct and the
reason is this object here is an array
and an array can be changed because that
rate can be changed it can't be a member
of a tuple so for a to bolt you have to
have subs of two balls you can see here
one two three then works as a tuple of a
tuple so you can do sub tuples of two
balls and you can do sub tuples of lists
and it even lets you do a sub list of a
tuple but don't ever do this because
this is gonna cause problems if you're
using an array and you have another
variable pointing to this array you're
gonna have problems once a tuple is set
you can't change anything in the tuple
without causing an error now we've
talked a little bit about lists and
tuples and we talked about a basic
iteration loop let's go ahead and look
at a while loop and let's create some
variables we'll do a number equals
integer input enter a number so we're
going to do is we're going to create a
variable called number we're going to
force it to be an integer so it has to
be one two three four it can be one
point five and the input is going to
prompt us it's gonna prompt us to enter
it a number on here for our while loop
then let's go ahead and take this number
and we're gonna say I equals number and
what we're going to do is we're gonna
show how to teach you how to find the
factorial we're gonna do with this
little one let's do fact equals one so
our factorial is gonna start as one and
then we're gonna say while I is greater
than or equal to one we're gonna loop
through so as long as I is greater than
or equal to one as long as this is true
as long as this logic is correct we're
gonna keep going through this loop and
you'll see it has an automatic indent
here and then we'll do our fact which is
1 equals fact times I now I went ahead
and wrote this out fact equals fact
times I but the Python Ian way is since
we're using the same variable and doing
simple math on it is to do fact equals I
this is the same thing fact equals
itself times I that's what this setup
works here then we'll do the same thing
with I we're gonna do I minus equals 1
so I equals itself minus 1 and you could
easily just just written this out as I
minus 1
same thing that's the same thing but
we'd like to make it look nice and clean
so we'll do I - equals one and let's go
down here and let's go ahead and print
out our factorial and then we'll walk
through the factorial let's print in our
second placeholder and then we have our
two placeholders which is gonna be
number comma factorial and just a quick
note here curved brackets so we are
looking at a tuple right here one it's
only used in this one line so once it's
done here it's gone but this is actually
the read as a tuple it's got the curved
brackets around it so we basically start
by taking our number and we're gonna run
it it's gonna prompt us enter a number
so we'll go ahead and enter the number
four and then each time through the loop
if as long as I equals number so I
equals the four equals two num and we
could have just left it as num we could
just kept taking it but we wanted to use
that for printing later on so for the
factor of and remember number is so we
take I equals number and then each
iteration is subtracts one and so we
take four we start off with a factorial
of 1 4 times 1 is 4 subtract 1 3 times 4
is 12 subtract 1 2 times 12 is 24
subtract 1 1 times 24 is 24 hopefully I
did that right so when we run this good
mekt in here hit the enter key there we
go the factorial of 4 is 24 so that is
the same as 1 times 2 times 3 times 4 or
in this case they did it in Reverse we
went 4 times 3 times 2 times 1 so
quickly to find the factorial of a
number you can see though that you could
insert just about any logic depending on
what you're working on and it'll keep
going through the loop until this
particular logic is met and you can
imagine that something that had no logic
to it whatsoever if I did something like
this where I did while 0 equals 0 it
would do this loop forever it would
never come out of the loop and
eventually you'll get an error I'm not
gonna do it it takes it a few minutes to
get an error down here but you get an
error saying it iterated to the loop and
had a while loop that never broke so you
gonna be a little careful when you're
using the while loop when doing this
just because you could end up with this
error coming up and your program locking
up and then you got to go troubleshoot
it and find out what you did wrong you
can see if you did instead of 0 maybe
you're in a rush
well when I equals eye or something like
that or maybe I equals well I change it
so if I didn't number it would actually
go away but if I did I equals I that
would be an issue now we already looked
at nested loops where we had the I and
the J we went through two different
series some of the things to be aware of
when you're doing these I showed you a
range but we can put that together and I
can do four we enter in a number and I
can do four I in reversed so we can put
a command word in there and it's gonna
reverse whatever is in here and if you
remember I had range as one of my
options 1 comma n plus 1 the reason
we're doing this particular setup is
most of our array start at 0 but let's
say I actually want to print out the
numbers well I want to start with one
range goes up to n so if this is like 5
it will go up to 4 so we have to add the
+1 in in the range so we have here new
word we've added in we have our range I
showed you earlier and so we have I in
range whatever number we put it and you
can create a nested loop for J in range
1 comma I plus 1 so now we're gonna go
forward in the loop and this is to print
well we'll just do I comma J so we'll
print out our two variables let's go
ahead and run that and it's gonna have
me enter a number
keep it small so it doesn't fill up my
screen we'll just do 3 and you can see
it starts with reversed 1 2 3 but in
this case it goes 3 2 1 3 2 2 1 and the
reason it does this is if you look at
this we have our 3 and then we have a
nested loop going the other way
this one goes 1 2 I plus 1 so in this
case I did 1 to I which is 3 and if you
do the logic on this you can actually
see how it comes up we ended with 3 2 3
3 2 1 2 2 1 1 so you can do a loop here
because here's our 3 it's hard to follow
sometimes when you do these loops in
reverse you'll see here we get 3 1
because I is 3 and then I plus 1 you
have I starts with range 1 so this is
going forward so we have 1 2 3 so that's
the J and then we get I equals two and
we get J equals 1 2 and then we get I
equals 1 and J
and sir president if the stuff actually
comes up if you're just starting off in
programming you're looking at this going
oh my gosh it's a little confusing
I certainly have done some logic and
data analysis where I'm looking at it
and I have to track it down and make
sure it's getting all the different
combinations I want and I'll end up with
some kind of pattern like this and it
does get confusing so you know if you
didn't follow that right off the bat
take a little time and just kind of
figure out the logic not a big deal but
it does come up so I'm gonna go ahead
and clear this we have one more major
data structure to cover which is
dictionaries you know we had lists we
had tuples we've looked at our basic
iteration loop and our while loop we've
seen nested loops we're gonna take just
a little detour here before we come to
dictionaries and we're gonna look at
functions very important threw this out
of here so if you remember way back when
we started this I discussed the fact
that you don't want to be copying and
pasting and redoing your code over and
over again so instead of doing that you
do an import your math because we have a
little math in there we're gonna create
what's called a function and in Python
you use the word def de F stands for
definition and we might call this circle
R so what we have here is a name I've
given it I've given it the name circle
we've labeled it as a definition so you
know that this is going to be a function
and we have a variable that goes into
the definition so when I call this
definition I'm gonna send it the
variable R and then when I come in here
we'll go area of goals math pie one of
the things you can do with math is just
pull up the value of pi times and if you
remember quickly we have power R comma
two we could also just do this for our
power we could also do our star star too
they actually do the same thing I always
like to put the brackets around it just
so we know that this is it'll do this
automatically if you remember from your
algebra you do your powers first before
you do multiplications and that kind of
thing but I still like to put brackets
around it just for my own readability so
we have the R squared times pi it gives
us the area and the perimeter we'll call
it perry equals two
if I remember correctly it's math pi
times R so this gives us our parameter
two times pi times the radius and then
we'll go ahead and just do a return area
and parameter so we can do with this as
if I let's just do caught a and P equals
circle and we'll have a circle of a
radius of four and if we do a print a
comma P and I run this you'll see down
here that it actually prints out the
area at fifty point two six whatever it
is and twenty five point one three
whatever it is so this way if we have
like a number of different evaluations
we're doing I've just created a function
circle that computes the area and the
perimeter and then we can just print it
out and I can reuse this over and over
again I don't have to copy and paste
these two lines of code in here I can
just call this function up and it will
bring this answer in for me and we could
certainly do this not just for a circle
we could also have definition triangle
and triangle has three sides so we have
three distances and we have area equals
math square root and if you remember
from your geometry oops I forgot a step
on here s equals zero point five times a
plus B plus C then if we take the half
the sum we can then do s times s let's
put our brackets in here s minus a and
this you have to have brackets on
because otherwise they'll do s times s
minus a versus s times s minus a and
we're going to multiply this s minus B
and we'll multiply that s minus C and
this would give us the area of the
triangle and the perimeter of the
triangle is simply a plus B plus C and
we can return area comma perimeter so
just like the circle have now created a
triangle and then we can also do this
for everything there's a little bit
easier def rectangle I guess we'll do L
comma B there's our colon and indent
make sure you how that indent in there
and
equals L times B and the perimeter
perimeter equals 2 times L plus B and
then we can return area comma perimeter
with the definition you don't have to
return something I'm actually showing
you a couple things here we're returning
two values so I can return one value you
can have no return on here it could just
be doing a print it could be saving it
to file so you do all kinds of things
with these you're not limited to
returning to variables and so you can
see in here we have our definition
circle or definition triangle and our
definition rectangle and each one
returns area and perimeter had a couple
little errors in here real quick fix
those so we have our three functions and
now we want to do something with them we
kept some unity there so they're
repeating themselves for all returning
the area and the perimeter but each one
needs different information so to do
that let's go ahead and get an input and
I'm gonna just do in for input you've
seen this before we have an integer
we're going to input select our scoop in
which is a carried return and then we'll
have one for circle a new line two for
triangle three for rectangle and then a
new line to enter our information in now
we want to do something with that so to
do something with that we use the if
statement I'll do if N equals one and
there's our hole and afterwards
remember two equal signs if you're doing
at logic they need the two equal signs
and if it's a circle we're gonna do R
equals oh let's do a float value now
float remember integer is like one two
three float one point two four point
five so on will do input enter radius
hit enter on there and then we do area
and perimeter equals and we don't have
to copy all the calculations for it
because we already have that up above
circle of R now we have a returning two
variables you could have returned one
variable you could have not returned two
variable maybe it just print something
or saves it to file in this case we're
gonna just return one variable for the
circle and we'll go ahead just run this
just because we can and if I go down
here and I type in one says in a radius
five and then it does nothing with that
so we want to actually do something with
this and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna print and just like before
we have our area we're gonna use a
placeholder or amber sign F scooped in
perimeter
scoop F amber sign and then our two
values that go into the two placeholders
and so if we run this and we select down
here triangle and it says enter the
radius will do a radius three enter and
then down here you'll see that it prints
out the area is twenty-eight point two
seven four three three four the
parameter is eighteen point eight four
nine nine five five six
so prints out our area and our perimeter
pretty good on here let's go back
because we did just the triangle so it
needs to know what happens if it is not
a triangle but instead is a not a circle
that instead is a triangle so we have an
L if if N equals one well we can do an
else if but as LF is of the command on
there we do our colon but we want in
equals two and so if N equals two we're
gonna go ahead and if you remember
correctly from that we had the three
sides of a triangle a B and C so we'll
do a equals I like the float so we'll
keep the float in there as a float value
just in case someone wanted to do a
float I'll do enter side one just copy
and paste that down there and because
I'm lazy I'm going to do another copy
and paste B equals and of course when
you do copy and paste your error carries
all the way down if you miss type
something side two and then we also want
C equals and this is going to be side
three there we go and then we need to
generate our area and our perimeter and
that equals triangle a b c and remember
that from above
so when you're coming up here here's our
circle it takes one value i didn't have
to call it r we could have called it
anything ours it's a radius so it's
pretty easy to track the nar would be
the best choice for that unless you have
something else that starts with R you
might have to add in rad for radius or
something like that triangle has three
sides so we did ABC and then the
rectangle we did breath by links so
we'll keep that up here we'll have ABC
for our three sides of our triangle and
then there's our area and we can go
ahead and even just run this so here we
go or is my double
second there we go so you can see what's
going on and here's our triangles - I
was gonna say inner side one so we'll
enter in two side two of three four and
so on and it computes the area and the
perimeter 2.90 four seven or 9.0 for the
perimeter and then if you continue the
logic we're going to do just a little
different here we could do another elsif
if we did another else if and you
entered a number that was not one two or
three it would not generate an area or a
perimeter but it would still try to
print them so we'll just do a catch-all
we'll say else and if else is here then
we need what breadth equals enter side
one again you to copy/paste remember
everything you copy and paste will show
up to haunt you a lot of times people
will actually retype all their code
instead of doing what I'm doing just to
avoid that so we have our breath and our
length input inner side and we'll go
ahead and do area and perimeter equals
and this is the rectangle L comma B is
fine doesn't matter what the order is
for a rectangle and now we can run this
and when we run this bring this back up
so you can see what's going on we select
one two or three and this could actually
be three four five or six because we did
an else statement instead of an LF well
we'll go ahead and type in 3 enter side
1 5 enter side to 10 and you can see
here it's going to be a perimeter of 30
in an area of 50 now 10 times 5 is 50
and 5 plus 5 plus 10 plus 10 is 30 so
you know as a cute little code and we've
looked at how to create definitions and
we've looped that in with our if
statement we have an LF which we've
added in and then or catch-all else
statement so what we're gonna do next is
we're gonna go back if you remember
before we were talking about clear this
out we talked about lists we talked
about tuples and we are now at what is a
dictionary so a dictionary uses what we
call key value pairs and when we had the
list
remember our list equals we'll just do
this real quick the list has one two
three four and if I print list to this
index is the key for a list so a list
has keys and the keys are basically 0 1
2 3
so 0 1 2 is the number 3 and as we get
printed out here this is the key this
index is the key for a list well in a
dictionary we create our own keys and so
I might do months so here's our value of
months and we denote a dictionary with
brackets so this lets me know that this
is going to be a dictionary and we
actually put one together I tend to find
that when I'm doing dictionaries I end
up with very large dictionaries the
music covering a lot of information but
let's say we're doing the months and we
want to know the days of the months we
can now create a key value in this case
January and the days 31 and if you
remember from our list let's go back
here and see list equals I keep redoing
this that you just left it 7 8 9 so from
here I can do print list 0 which is
gonna be the first place when we run
that we get 7 with months if I want to
print I can print months there's our
variable here's our square brackets just
like a list but instead I'm gonna put in
January and so this is now our key here
and let's run that and you'll see it
prints out 31 and we can iterate through
our months just like we did before so
let's do for EM I'm gonna stick with key
for key in months and I'm gonna have it
print the key and then I'm gonna have it
print months of the key let's go ahead
and run this and so we'll see here that
our prints the key January 31st February
28th and so on followed by the months
and of course we can make this kind of a
fancy it up a little bit adding a four
let's do a placeholder string day count
is and then at our place we're back here
and this is take this that way we have
our nice format going to so it looks
nice and hopefully I didn't miss
something when I run this I got an e
MERIS let's fix that
yeah we run this and we'll see we get
for January the date count is 31 for
February D count is 28 and oh wait a
second what if it was a leap year well
with months we can go in here and here
is our value we'll just copy February
and in a leap year February has 29 days
so I can now change months February to
29 and we can run this and now we see
January is now 29 so the takeaway from
this is the dictionary is kind of like a
subset of lists if function is very much
like a list and that the value it can
also be another dictionary it can be
tuples it can be a list it can be an
array which we're gonna cover in just a
minute a string characters numbers
integers float value you put almost
anything in the value just like you can
put anything in a list the big thing is
the key this key can't be changed I
can't go in and change I can delete the
key and add a new key in but I cannot
change the key and this is important
because I might have a key my key equals
let's call it November comma December so
here's my key I'm gonna create a new
value in here and I can do months and my
key equals I'll make this equal to
months November plus months
I'll make this December so what I'm
doing is I'm adding the days from both
months and let me close this because I
put it in the wrong spot
put it here after January so I've added
in here November December and if you
look at this is a key code so I've
created a key code out of a tuple
remember a tuple can't be changed so
you'll see this in key codes where you
might have a number of different values
that are your index for your dictionary
and tuples are used a lot in
dictionaries because you might have
multiple values that are locked in and
very important I don't know how many
times I've done word counts and
documents like you might be going
through the document and looking up how
many times does January occur in all the
bills passed for the United States in
the last year and it says January is the
word and then the account goes here
those occurred once twice three and it
just keeps incrementing that as it goes
through and looks up the any words are
in the document so you can use this for
a lot of things but dictionaries it's
important to know that you have your key
and you have your value you can change
the value but you can't change the key
and the value can also be like I said a
dictionary and it can also be a list it
can be a tuple that can be a
that's whatever you needed to be and
this brings us to one more data type so
we've had lists we've had tuples we've
had the dictionary we're now going to do
the actual array now I mentioned earlier
that and this is one of the confusions
in Python if you're coming from another
programming language there is the list
and then there is an array the array is
probably more close to what you actually
think of an array if you're programming
in Java or C++ or another programming
script because it's typeset I remember I
can put a string in here in the list I
can put an integer but whatever datatype
I want in the list I can put a sub list
in the list but with an array you can't
do that so we're gonna do from array
import we're gonna import all their
different code from the array so we're
importing the module in this case we're
importing all the parts of array you
could just do import array here for what
we're doing and we'll create a variable
we'll call it ARR and we'll set that
equal to an array we're gonna type set
it that's what the is it actually stands
for integer in this case signed integer
and then we'll send it a list the list
might be - 1 2 3 - 4 5 now the array
inherits from the list so almost all the
functionality you have in the list is
the same for the array the difference is
we've typeset it we force this to be
integer only like I can go in here and I
can go print arr oh let's just do the
students ero just because there we go if
I print the ARR of 0 it's negative 1 so
just like an array it's gonna go to this
point we can also do a IR of 0 equals
let's make it minus 99 and if I run that
you'll see it now equals 99 but what
happens if I do 99.999 and we run that
it's gonna give me an error why because
I've told it it can only take integers
so this is locked in and it doesn't
allow me to put anything else other than
a signed integer now if we go to our
Bing search do Python 3 array type and
the reason I say to do array type is
because you'll get a lot of different
returns for just array and you'll want
to go down to where you see the official
docs python.org
and you can go straight to 3 library and
see what
has on there but this is the best way to
do it well not the best way this is one
way to do it a lot of people just go
straight to the Python site and look it
up and you'll see that they have in a
list of all the different arrays you can
have and here is our I signed integer
you can do all kinds of different things
from float to double to unsigned
character and sign character and short
and if you scroll down you can type the
see what type of array it is type code
item size there's our append straight
from the list extend from bytes from
file from list there's Unicode there's
our index so we can pull up the array
index we can insert by the ways you can
insert in a regular list pop remove same
thing is on the list so it's pretty much
the same as the list there's a few other
things in here that you can do and
there's a few things you can't do
obviously one of them is signed a non
integer value in here so we've covered a
lot we've covered lists tuples
dictionaries array we've covered
iterating through the data we've covered
both like for eye and range we've also
covered the while loop and we did the if
LF and else so you have a look at that
we know looked at the input it's time to
have a little fun let's do a short
program and we're gonna play a game of
hangman so let's go ahead and create a
hangman on here and I have a preset list
like a good cook okay I don't know about
a good cook that has dynamite and
stationery in there thing or anaconda
bring in the snake but we have words
apples anaconda jasmine dynamite and
stationary so those are gonna be our
five words and you could put any words
you want on here certainly on there and
we would have had an imported random
random is a random number generator and
there's a lot of there's some
functionality and there are different
options but we're going to use that to
select our word and so our selection
will call se l equals words so it's
gonna look at this list of words and
random rand integer we'll create an
integer it's real important that we do
an integer because if I look for the
index 1.5 it'll give me an error because
there is no 1.5 there's just 0 1 2 3 4
and so we're gonna do a random integer
between 0 and 4 now a little different
than our range where we didn't include
the last one the random does so 0 to 4
and then
go ahead and print introduction to the
game let's play hangman you have five
chances it's kind of a guaranteed win
since we have five words and then we're
gonna do length equals Lin of cell and
this is just gonna count it so I'm
randomly picking out a word up here and
if it picked up apples and say hey this
word has one two three four five six
letters in it and we can do this we can
actually do this to print selection
comma links let's just run that and
you'll see that let's play hangman you
have five chances and it did randomly
pick out apples it says it has six
letters one two three four five six just
like we counted on there and then let's
create a list equals an empty list and
then we'll do four I and range zero to
link now remember the length is six it
doesn't include the six but we're
including the zero so we do zero to
length so this is gonna be zero to five
which is six it equals six on there but
we're just gonna take our list and let's
append will append an underscore so as
we guess we can start doing things with
our guesses on here so there we go for I
in range zero links list append and we
have just a row of blank lines and we
said we're gonna give you five chances
so chances equals five filled equals
zero so you're starting off with the
score of zero and five guesses and it
says Wow chances is greater than zero so
you still have chances left usually be
doing a lot of equals and just like you
can you do this an F - it's a logic
statement you can have chances greater
than zero and filled not equal to length
so as we fill and we're gonna count this
we're gonna count how many letters are
in there and keep track of that so once
zero hits the length we're done that
means we got it and we'll create a flag
sometimes I use well we'll just call
this flag equals zero let me go ahead
and close this down just a little bit so
you can see what we're doing a little
better and then we want to go ahead and
get a character from as an input so our
character is an input make guess ABC you
know whatever is on there for index
comma I and
numerate cell and this is really a cool
line remember how I talked about key
value pairs this is a list so the index
is the key
I could easily put key in here with a
dictionary when we did the months if I
had done this it would have returned the
month and the value so you'll see key
value here sometimes in this case index
comma I and we're going to enumerate
over the selection that's the random
word we picked out and it says if I
equals character we want to do something
so hey I guessed one my iya looks like
the character list of index equals
character so what I've done is I've said
hey we found a character that's in our
selection the indexes are going to match
so this is one of those things where
having the going through a pointer
versus an actual value we've used the
index as our pointer and we're going to
set that equal to the characters we'll
fill it out for us and we say oh you got
one
so we one do filled we're gonna
increment it by one so remember if I put
the plus sign before the equal we're
adding one to fill this is the same as
filled equals fill the plus one the
shorthand and we'll say flag equals one
so once we've gone through all the
indexes and we filled in each character
that matches because some of these have
like anaconda has three ace so you would
have fill in all three A's on there
that's why we use the flag and you could
have easily done flag equals true flag
equals false but we've gone through the
index and once we've looped through the
index we know that the flag is either 0
or 1 and if it's 1 we got it if not if
Lag equals 0 then we did we don't got it
we didn't get the right answer and so
chances want to subtract your chance is
you only get 5 we're gonna take it down
by one and then print you have put a
placeholder there chances remaining and
then of course we have our placeholder
and chances keeps track of how many
times they miss guess there's a couple
ways we can do a next setup on here in
the while statement we could do
if filled print Congrats
you won and let's bring this back once
and I want a part of the loop up there
but we do we'll need to know what was
filled forgot a step there will do for I
and list and that's print i + space
comma end equals there we go so what
we're doing here for i and list we're
gonna print out all the letters so we
print i print a space between each one
so it's either going to be an underscore
or the letter we guessed and we've added
this is kind of an interesting statement
on here end equals empty so that means
instead of printing it on the next line
it's gonna print it on one line and then
we want to go ahead and let see make a
guess I always like to let's add a scoop
in here for readability and it skipping
back down so we've gone through we've
got our guests we printed out what we've
guessed so far if we get to the end of
the while statement where filled is not
equal to length so once it's equal to
length we're done or chances are done it
then comes in here it says if filled
equals length print congrats you one
else print will be nice about it we
won't say anything mean and I like lose
or anything like that will just say
better luck next time
and let's go ahead and run this open up
our window down here and hit the run and
it says let's play hangman you have five
chances make a guess so I'll type in a
and look at that I got a and let's see
make a guess let's see what should be my
guest now can't be anaconda this 2p I'm
gonna guess Apple I got the Apple and
then let's go ahead and do oh let's make
a wrong guess s make a guess apples oh I
forgot s was in there so we'll do a d DS
not in there you have four chances
remaining oh no maybe there's e okay so
apples
how about Q no Q I got three chances
left and we'll just go ahead and do L
there we go congratulations you won yeah
you've won so you can see here he wrote
a simple code with our while loop that
just loops through guesses and made a
basic hangman we've covered a lot of
things today which is exciting
I love
bring lots of different information so
hopefully you've picked up on some basic
Python which is exciting definitely if
you have questions leave leave notes
down below in the YouTube video or come
visit us at www.fortuigence.com